[Music]
foreign
conditions such as heart disease stroke
cancer diabetes they're common they're
costly and they're highly preventable
and are also becoming much more
prominent globally so I think as a
societal perspective I think it's really
important to consider all of these
conditions that really play a large role
in our Health Care system as far as
burden and also the issue on individuals
and families that suffer from these
chronic conditions
[Music]
a number of our faculty are very
involved in cancer research where they
have really gone from understanding what
some of the risk factors are for
recovery and then thinking about not
just what are some of these lifestyle
issues like being more active managing
your weight managing other risk factors
but then going to targeted interventions
and interventions that are being brought
into the clinics so that they have
really high impact for those at risk
two of our students in the department
have been working with the data set
looking at recovery of young patients
with heart disease at whether or not
perceived discrimination might be
associated with recovery in the first
year after a young person had a heart
attack and what they found was that
there was an association between
individuals that reported high levels of
perceived discrimination and worse
outcomes in terms of a symptomatology we
also out of our department had a paper
that just got published in the journal
stroke that was looking at disparities
in National trends of recurrent stroke
so there are about eight hundred
thousand Strokes a year about 200 000
people have a recurrent stroke we were
interested in understanding whether
there could be differences by age sex
socioeconomic status and where you live
and what we found is over a long period
of time from 2001 to 2017 in fact there
were areas in the country that had
persistently High recurrent rates and
these particular areas is were also
where there was Health inequity there
were differences in social demographic
characteristics and it really
underscores I think the importance of
good disease surveillance using
epidemiologic methods to not only
understand acute conditions but aspects
of long-term care and Recovery we need
to think of many aspects of recovery for
the individual what unique
characteristics do they have that may
impact the way that they recover from a
chronic illness or an acute condition I
think also a very important aspect is
how do we get health messaging across
different communities how do you tell
the stories that really have effective
consequences not everything fits every
person and so I think a lot of our
faculty are really working on tailored
messaging not only for different
populations but different health
conditions and I think that's an
essential component that we need to be
thinking about globally
[Music]